so let's have a look at this now the
first question is find the exact value
of 10 PI a
ok which makes you question half a
second because you're like okay 22 and
1/2 degrees like what what exact value
is that thankfully that we've been doing
questions on this for ages now right so
even though planner is not exact it's
pretty close to another angle which we
do know the exact value for what are we
going to get this in terms of plan for
right
so PI then is half of planned for so
we're going to use the double angle
sorry the half angle results which are
really just the double angle results in
reverse tattoo X what's just the regular
expansion okay so the X that I'm
interested in here is reply on eight
which makes that 10 2x over their file
form okay so that's going to give me
this 10 plan for there and all my tampon
eights are gonna be on this right-hand
side
okay so now what okay so 10 up on 4 and
45 degrees is just equal to 1 okay now
I'm gonna skip a step there alright take
a seat oh yeah I'm gonna bring that over
the other side so because this is just
one right something I can cross multiply
so I've got 1 minus 10 squared there
okay and others shuffle around a little
bit to make the core --decor a little
obvious
okay so I'm guessing we'll get if I
rearranged it quickly the signs are all
I think yeah
Donn's one factorize nicely does it so
I'm just going to launch straight into
the formula okay so this is just minus B
plus or minus and so on okay so can we
through the numbers what we start with
yeah oh yeah that's right yeah yeah yeah
that's minus to plus or minus that rude
a little bit and renate is 2 root 2 okay
so I can I can take that out so that's
minus 1 plus or minus root 2 okay so yes
so just like usual it's a quadratic so
that's why we have two solutions but
okay what what am i saying this is equal
to what my solving for
I'm solving for 10 or an acute angle
right what yeah I don't even need to
really do that I can say that tan of an
acute angle must be greater than that's
enough of an argument so therefore I
can't be possibly be minus 1 minus root
2 because that's very negative so
therefore it's the positive answer only
okay great so there's all this power all
right so then the next question
part 2 says and there's a hint right and
it's not a actually it's a hint so
otherwise hence right there looking in
it's just right so which is the same
idea like okay I'm gonna take this and
somehow I'm gonna get from that to this
okay now what IDs do we have here
what ways can we go about this
okay now I could I could do a similar
thing to what I did here right I can say
well 3 PI on 8 big pie name that is PI
on a plus plan for right isn't it yes
right yeah so I can say that's 10 of
let's see
hi on 8 plus on 4
ok so now I can do the expansion right
what is the expansion what what long I
haven't said about anyways I'm just
saying I'm still using this I'm still
using it right so wait wait we're not
liking this idea why are we so
dissatisfied with this answer it's us
you like this will take forever
well at least I'll take a little while
now I will I will do this just for the
sake of it because you know I actually
think that bad ok but what would be a
faster way can we work out a faster way
okay now that's that that shouldn't make
you um raise your eyebrows right so they
want us to show but this is actually
equal to the reciprocal of this right
this is this is root 2 minus 1 okay and
they want us to show that 10 of this
angle is 1 on root 2 minus 1 which makes
you think okay there must be a closer
connection than just this now what kind
of connection can be used 3.8 is is
still a cube and pyre Nate's acute so I
can put this in a right angle triangle
it'll work right so what would it look
like
here's my right angle so there's PI on 8
okay so what's the other angle
okay so what else do I need to put on
here no is that's helpful
okay so tanahpaya date yes and I can
write it like that which I know seems a
bit silly but it shows there's a ratio
involved right the ratio I'm after is
opposite on adjacent so that makes this
group 2 minus 1 and that's okay
so from this triangle I give it some
names okay so the reason why I'm giving
it a name is so that I can connect it to
a right angle triangle rather it's not
some identity that I'm using okay 10:03
fly on a is just well it's opposite on
adjacent right and as you've noticed it
is just one lock okay I just didn't take
a comparison how long would it take
okay what's the expansion turns hi on 8
+ 10 1 - now this is not that bad just
ham plan for is just 1 right so what I
get I'm gonna get root 2 minus 1 plus 1
1 minus root 2 minus 1 times 1 let's say
you just get yes that's right isn't it
and now I can divide it into 5
I think it was that bad but it's true
it's true this is kind of a more elegant
way to go back if you're gonna make an
argument about a triangle
you better have a triangle if you want
to make this kind of argument much like
the integration the areas the definite
integrals of inverse trig functions if
you are going to make an argument that's
geometric you need to have a picture
there